there are parts of Dark Souls two's law
that don't quite add up
unknown histories certain character
motivations origins of the curse and of
beings like the Giants these are unknown
elements and that's not really a bad
thing
just like in Dark Souls 1 these unknown
elements will act as the gaps in the law
we fill for ourselves in this video
though I want to question that law my
best videos are based on interpretation
so before I do any interpreting I want
you to understand which parts of the law
currently don't have any concrete
answers I want you to know what topics
need answering when the DLC hits and I
want you to try and find answers for
yourselves let's make it a bit more fun
though sometimes I'll engage in rampant
speculation and when I do this you'll
see this little button light up for
example did you know that Gavin's wheel
and deal quote is in reference to how he
wheels dark divert ground all around to
get to different locations so that he
can pay for his crippling alcohol
addiction to Heineken you can find
shortcuts to topics in the description
we have four major topics and the first
one we're going to talk about is the
opening cutscene so in this cutscene we
have to answer four questions who are we
where are we who is the woman and most
importantly when are we the most obvious
question in answer is who we are we are
a wandering undead it seems as if we've
lost our memory of our past life based
on the dialog and the fact that these
two are melting away the second question
where are we in the cutscene at the
start I actually think that it's
irrelevant we're just a wanderer who
comes upon this old woman but it becomes
relevant when we come upon the ruins of
drangleic and considering these ruins I
think what's most important is when we
are the old lady tells us that one day
we're going to stand upon the decrepit
gate of drangleic without really knowing
why this puts our actions in drangleic
in the past so when we arrive at this
portal we are traveling to a kingdom
that existed a long time ago and that's
where the entire game takes place so
that's significant so the next question
who is this old lady to lay this
prophecy upon us well there is a fourth
Firekeeper mentioned in the fire keeper
hut a fire keeper who left
others a fair time ago I believe this
cinematic old lady is the fourth fire
keeper and that's for a few reasons for
one she's wearing the red fire keeper
garb but what's really interesting is
that we have a lot of evidence that
she's an aged emerald Harold
firstly in the credits we're told that
there is a young and an old version of
Shanna watt secondly she has very
similar dialogue to the Harold at the
dragon Eyrie when she says that we shall
walk those grounds without really
knowing why and lastly the Harold
mentions that it was her own
manifestation that led us to drangleic
the Emerald Herald is also called fire
keeper in game by novel on the guardian
of the fire fire the fourth fire keeper
the connection between the Harold and
the aged woman has also been confirmed
by people who are working on the
official guide so now that we know that
the woman is an aged version of the
Emerald Herald we have our first
question why is she laying this prophecy
upon us why is she sending us back the
old women in the hut say you spoke to
that kind or dear didn't you you're
finished implying that they know what
the Emerald Herald is trying to do the
dialogue also reminds us that they've
seen other undead passed through here
all who've shared the same fate
hollowing they have this air of disdain
for what the Emerald Herald of the
fourth fire keeper seems to be trying to
do their sister seems to be sending
undead back to drangleic through this
limbo
called things betwixt perhaps in some
effort to alter the past so what past
needs to be altered if you watched my
video on the ending you might know our
characters goal in this game is to link
the fire the young emerald heralds goal
is to get us to link the fire the
Emerald Herald Ty Lee guides the undead
who come through majula undead who
appear to have been sent from the future
I've always thought that the Emerald
heralds dialogue sounded really tired
and weary and if she's had to guide
hundreds and hundreds of undead along
the same path to their hallowed fate
then I could explain why in fact this
whole thing is actually somewhat
reminiscent of how our character in Dark
Souls 1 is sent back in order to stop
the spread of the abyss with manners
think about it the entire game of Dark
Souls 2 is about the cycles things that
happened in the
just game in Lordran happen again in
drangleic the framework is the same but
the players change so just like in Dark
Souls 1 when we were sent back to all
asil to stop Manas and his abyss were
being sent back to drangleic in order to
stop nashandra spreading her own abyss
and that's my theory anyway
speaking of cycles though a lot of you
don't like the idea of cycles and that's
ok do bear in mind though that these are
concepts much more accepted in Eastern
mythology's than in western ones it
really drives through that hopelessness
of what we're doing but if we are to see
a Dark Souls 3 then I hope it deals with
our breaking of the cycle somehow
because if we just get another cycle in
Dark Souls 3 that would be pretty
disappointing so there wasn't too much
rampant speculation on the discussion of
this opening I think a lot of this
speculation can be fairly valid if you
find any loopholes in my theories then
let me know let's move on to something
you can help me with though the Giants
we'll start with the facts what we know
long ago
the Queen came to King vendrick alone
from a faraway land she warned him of a
looming threat across the seas the
Giants it's not said whether they
actually were a threat or not but the
king crossed the ocean defeated the
Giants pillaged their land and brought
back a prize so two questions come up
with this topic who are the Giants and
what was stolen from them and we don't
have definite answers to these questions
it's an example of a really major
missing plot point in the game
ultimately I think this might be
revealed in some sort of DLC but there
are a few ideas floating around
currently about who the Giants are so
I'll clue you in on some of my favorite
ones and I'll let you make your own
decisions in terms of a timeline we know
that the Giants appeared after nashandra
came to vendrick she came from a far-off
land and warned him of the Giants
calling them a looming threat from
across the seas my interpretation is
that she used this information to get
closer to vendrick giving him apparently
vital information and conveniently
placing her close to the throne were
they actually a threat probably not
captain Drummond calls the invasion of
the Giants misguided barbarism and I'm
inclined to believe it if I had to draw
a parallel to Dark Souls 1 I'd say it's
similar to how Gwyn engaged
the ancient dragons so who are these
Giants honestly I'm just inclined to
believe that the Giants are an entirely
new entry to the soul series since there
isn't really much evidence that they've
existed in some other form in Dark Souls
1 one theory I do kind of like calls
them a reincarnation of dragons the
ancient dragon drops a giant soul after
all and while everyone assumes that the
giant soul was a part of the dragon due
to experimentation with aldia what if
the devs wanted us to come to the
conclusion that the dragon was a giant
this is further emphasized when you
consider the plaque on the back of the
medulla obligated as being Lord Ron
who's to say that the dragons aren't
coming back in some other form the only
other link I have to them being the same
being as dragons is that Giants grow
into trees and these trees could be the
arch trees of the Dragons in some sort
of long evolutionary cycle but this is a
long shot also in reference to the
plaque it could be talking about how the
Giants left drangleic not necessarily
that they came to drangleic all it says
is that they returned home so since the
obelisk is a war monument I guess it
kind of makes sense that they're
commemorating the fact that the Giants
left that they retreated you know anyway
other theories say that they're the
Lords from Lord Rama that perhaps this
is the withered form they could take
once they lose their souls a few people
noticed that the Giants Lords outfit
looked a lot like gwyn's
it doesn't really explain why they grow
into trees though so I wouldn't say that
they're the same race and if drangleic
is Lord run why would the Giants be
elsewhere so as much as I'd love an
explanation of what the Giants are it
doesn't look like we have a solid theory
just yet
moving on vendrick brought a prize back
from the Giants when he invaded and
there's a lot of speculation regarding
what this could have been whatever it
was it has to be related to Hendricks
ability to create golems since Drummond
directly states that he brought back a
prize and then the golems materialized
so some say it's the Lord vessel which
is cracked in the basement of the
a mansion the Lord vessel holds Souls
and studying it could have given
vendrick the ability to place Souls into
inanimate objects another common
reasoning is that this would explain all
the Lord Souls from Dark Souls 1 being
present in Dark Souls 2 though this is
problematic reasoning for a few reasons
one it's already been fairly established
that drangleic is a reincarnation of
Lordran so why would the Lord vessel be
overseas in the first place and two we
know that vendrick had already risen to
power and defeated the four old ones by
the time he attacked the Giants so it's
unlikely that it's the Lord vessel some
say it's the ashen mist heart which
allows you to delve into the memories of
the withered this could explain how
vendrick and aldea peered into the very
essence of the soul though it doesn't
really explain how they developed the
ability to create golems and some say
it's the throne of want itself I don't
like any of these suggestions but I like
this theory the most for a few reasons
a the throne seems built for a much
taller being B you need the giant
skinship for the doors to even open
kinship means to be blood-related or to
share characteristics or origins and see
nashandra implies that she wants access
when she bitterly remarks that vendrick
never sat the true throne so it could
have been the motivation for her to
invade the Giants in the first place and
D the throne is surrounded by golems
that only react to the Giants kinship I
don't think any of these opinions are
definitively true or false I think the
intention of the developers was that you
were never supposed to know quite what
vendrick stole and this is what makes
new Chandra's intentions so vague and
it's what makes the Giants intentions so
alien and once we figure this out I feel
like many other aspects of the game will
fall into place
speaking of nashandra though there's a
fair bit that doesn't quite add up with
her so nashandra is well known to be a
fragment of madness at this point she
also looks a lot like dusk who - both
steals and releases in Dark Souls ones
DLC if we follow this reasoning while
we're on the topic of dusk we can assume
that a dusk is nashandra and is more
than just a damsel in distress in the
first game
her name is dusk after all which means
to grow dark or be the fragment of Manas
that develops into nashandra sin
he gets an impression of dusk or see the
fragment in facts dusk and grows within
her they're all possible and they're all
interesting I really like to think that
there's more going on with a dusk since
her name seems to imply a little bit
more when we meet nashandra she's
sitting on the simple throw alone no one
quite seems to know where vendrick is
but her with vallega saying the Queen
has taken him that must be what it looks
like to vallega
the Queen tells you to visit vendrick
then when he's dead proclaims that
drangleic is no longer she then tells
you to seek the throne and do what needs
to be done so she's guiding you in the
right direction she's guiding you to the
throne aka the kiln in order to link the
fire so why is she doing this she says
it's what must be done so it's almost
like she's given up almost like she
knows what's going to happen and if the
popular theory is right there isn't much
that she can do before vendrick died he
locked half the kingdom away behind seal
gates only he could open and then he
shut himself away so deeply in the crypt
that nashandra couldn't easily follow so
we get to the end of the game and we
fight nashandra she tells us how we've
proven ourselves to her and how we will
become one with the dark her intentions
are still vague the only conclusion that
I can come to is that she led us to the
throne knowing that we were the only one
who could get that far since she
couldn't she then plans to usurp us at
the last second and ascend the throne
for herself
the official guide says that she's found
you the new heir to the throne so it
seems like she's been waiting for a
really really long time why then are we
able to challenge nashandra over and
over again in the throne room
once we've lost shouldn't she have
already won I mean she's just standing
there in front of the throne shouldn't
she have the ability to ascend it for
herself and the only reasonable
explanation to this is a that it's a
gameplay oversight or B that she can't
take the Giants kinship from you which
means that she clearly knows very little
about what the throne is even after
craving it so much her intentions are
truly baffling and I feel like there's
something missing here
hope that there is and then there's the
ending cutscene I've always been
confused by the Herald's dialogue here
so there's this cycle where the age of
fire fades to embers and then it's on
the cusp of becoming a Dark Age and an
undead comes along and links the fire
starting the cycle over again so why
does the Emerald Herald say that we're
the one to break the shackles of fate it
sounds like we're staying within the
strict guidelines of fate doesn't it in
the ending cutscene she says once the
fire is linked souls will flourish anew
and all of this will play out again she
then goes on to say it is your choice to
embrace or renounce this is she
referring to how we can link the flame
and choose an age of dark or is she
saying that it's our choice to link the
flame or renounce the cycle completely
and then there's the nature of the
throne-room itself the Herald says that
nashandra covets the first flame and the
great soul she implies that these things
exist within the throne somehow since
nashandra comes here knowing full well
that you'll take the throne and link the
fire so where are these things
furthermore do you think linking the
fire takes place when you enter new
game+ is this what the herald means when
she says that souls will flourish in you
I personally don't think she's referring
to New Game+ but many people do anyway
that does it for major topics in terms
of minor stuff we also have to discover
what happened to aldea who were the
prince and princess of Alken and Ven why
is Ornstein here we still don't know and
what's the deal with the high Knights so
if you have any idea on these minor
topics let me know in the thread in the
description and with this video I really
just wanted to drive discussion to these
areas I want to put up the gaps in the
law for public debate so that you guys
are aware of what's known and what's not
I've got a link in the description to a
place where we can discuss all these
questions and when all three pieces of
DLC are out we might just have to
revisit these topics and see how far
we've come until next time guys